- En 2016, 2017, 2018, j'étais
en arrêt de travail.
- C'est ça.
- J'étais pas à l'école, j'étais
plus capable davavavailler.
- De courtes impulsions
électriques sur une zone précise
du cerveau durant une quinzaine
de minutes, cette thérapie
permet menenenant à Camille
Heyden Dubé de soigner
les graves symptômes que
peut lui causer sa dépression
saisonnière.
LLLLLLLLE HEYDEN DUBÉ
- Je suis très fatiguée,
j'ai beaucoup de difficulté
de concentration,
l'anxiété monte à des niveauxcas
difficilement fonctionnelle
quand ca arrive vraiment au picf
et cause peu d'effets
secondaires.
Dr JEAN-PHILIPPE MIRON,
psychiatre, CHUM
- Avec des technologies comme
la stimulation magnétique
transcrânienne, il semble
qu'on vient normaliser
l'activité de ce grand réseau
de neurones là pour un peu
le diminuer, on pourrait dire,
pour venir atténuer les flammes.
- En moyenne, un traitement
s'étend sur six semaines à
raison de plusieurs séances
hebdomadaires.
Avez-vous vu une différence
remarquable au moment où vous
avez changé de traitement?
- Oui, honnêtement,
les traiteme
ça m'a rendu ma vie.
- La stimulation magnétique
transcranienne est prescrite
de plus en plus fréquemment
au CHUoioioioioigner les cas
de dépression sévères, ceux
qui répondent peu ou pas du tout
aux médicaments.
Son efficacité est démontrée.r %
entrent en rémission et 30 %
voient leur état s'améliorer.
- Il faut comprendre que
la stimulation magnétique
transcranienne n'est plus
expérimentale. Il y a quelques
années ce l'était encore, mais
depuis 2016, depuis les nouvea
guides de pratiques qui sont
sortis, c'est vraiment reconnu
comme un traitement efficaceààà.
- Lorsqu'une dépression résiste
aux traitements habituels destie
peut avoir recours à un implant,
qu'on glisse sous la peau, près
de la clavicule du patient.
L'appareil stimule
électriquement un nerf connecté
directement à son cerveau,
24 heures sur 24, à un rythme
établi en fonction de
ses besoins spécifiques.
L'implant de Lise Ladouceur
émet une pulsation à toutes
les cinq minutes.
LISE LADOUCEUR
- C'est une esesesesesesest
un pacemaker, c'est un
stimulateur, mais au lieu
d'être branchée sur le coeur,
moi c'est sur le nerf vague.
Comme , , , , , , , il y a
une petite stimulation et
ma voix change, cest le seul
effet secondaire, quand même!
- Pour elle aussi,
ococococococoche a fait toute
la différence.
- Après quinze ans de dépression
majeure, j'avais plus beaucoup
d'espoir. La souffrance était
très, très grande puis c'était
pour moi la dernière option.
- Au Québec, il y a 400 000
nouveaux cas de dépressions
chaque année et on considère
que le tiers sont difficiles
à traiter. Pourtant, seul trois
centres hospitaliers et
quelques cliniques privées
offrent actuellement ce service.
Dr PAUL LESPÉRANCE, Département
psychiatrie, Université Montréal
- Là il commence a y avoir un
changement dans l'attitude je
dirais, et dans l'intérêt
démontré par nos coll
disent comment je peux offrir ça
Des fois c'est en nous référant
les patients,
une certaine volumétrie, bien,
on va de développer à l'interne
et on va vous réserver les cas
plus coriaces ou les plus
complexe
- Utilisé couramment aux États-
Unis et en France, cette
thérapie fait aussi l'objet
de recherches de pointe depuis
quelques années.- - - - - - - -a
médication, il faut quand même
le dire, depuis trente ans.
On a beaucoup de molécules mais
il y a beaucoup de molécules qui
sont similaires à celles qui
existaient déjà mais avec des
profils d'effets secondaires
plus intéressants. Mais des
révolutions moléculaires, il y
en a peu et ... donc il faut se
tourner vers d'autres option
(23)
Bien sûr, il s'agit encore d'un
traitement alternatif, qui a ses
limites.
Mais parfois, il peut accomplir
de véritables miracles.
"Les semaines qui ont suivi les
traitements, j'ai remarqué que
quand je sortais dehors et que
je voyais le ciel bleu, je
ressentais l'espèce de petite
joie que j'avais complètement
perdu avant. Je me suis mis à
prendre des photos de tous les
ciels bleus que je pouvais
attraper, quand
beau nuage ou quoi que ce soit,
J'en ai plein sur mon téléphone
parce que tout d'un coup, oups,
j'étais à nouveau capable de
ressentir de la joie. Ca m'a
fait vraauauauauauauauauauaucoup
de bien.